hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another south by southwest
2022 interview i am so happy to welcome
maria bakalova to the channel who is
celebrating not one but two south by
southwest movies this year hello
congratulations hello thank you so much
before we get to the movie specifically
i obviously have award season on the
brain right now and wanted to look back
a little to pave our way to these newest
projects so i imagine there's probably a
million answers to this question i'm
about to ask you but what were some of
your biggest takeaways from the oscar
experience because i always love asking
people what oscars mean to them just
because i don't know sometimes we could
kind of like lose the meaning of what
we're fighting for and celebrating that
entire experience oh my gosh thank you
so much and yes we're right in the race
of the new year of the oscars and it's
so exciting to see it especially having
the chance to be a part of it last year
it's been just
like a dream because being eastern
european being bulgarian being from the
other side of the world
seems
impossible feels impossible to be a part
of something that global and being seen
and being hurt um so
it still feels like a dream that last
year happened and i'm just thrilled that
people heard about
places like bulgaria places like
um
moldova ukraine serbia macedonia um
this is my country this is my region of
the world and i'm proud to be bulgarian
i'm proud to be eastern european so
maybe that's one of the biggest
takeaways which
i felt and experienced that so many
people from my region of the world
reached out to me
saying that their hopes has never been
stronger and their dreams have never
been bigger that things are possible and
we just have to dream big and dare to
achieve our dreams and if we do it maybe
we will i love that so much all right so
you go through that whole experience you
want to celebrate your wonderful
achievement but being in the awards
season race puts all that pressure on
you because you want to celebrate what
you accomplish but it's also an
opportunity to look forward and use that
platform to you know line up things for
the future so as that award season run
was winding down what are some of your
top priorities and goals so that in the
future you can get the projects that
speak to you most
well first of all i will further be
grateful to
sasha baron cory and the whole team of
borat
people behind the camera people in front
of the camera everybody that was
extremely dedicated to make this movie
for giving me the chance to be working
with them uh and opening the door of the
western cinema to an eastern european
actor
so my dream and goal is to create more
opportunities again for people from my
region of the world artists like mina
and vessel my director is from women to
cry that i'm here right now with uh and
just make this exchange that has been
happening before i think in the 90s in
the 20s and then something happened i
think the cold war world war ii where
the bridge between the western cinema
and eastern european actors have been
broken completely so i think it's time
for us to reunite again and stand up for
each other and
create more projects that
embrace different countries embrace
different nations especially in the rise
of this craziness that is happening
right now
in this place in eastern europe uh it's
crucial for us as artists to
to be seen as
as
human beings because
i'm a little bit scared and
cautious about
how it's a generalization
of for example people from russia
being considered
even more as the bad people the evil
people just because of the government
that is making the decisions
for them uh so that's why my goals are
to just try to portrait
people from my region of the world in
the western cinema because
the exchange and the collaboration that
we can create is crucial for us for
just the state of art sake of art um and
yeah maybe that's my biggest takeaway if
i can
use my platform to speak for
all these artists all around the world
that haven't been hurt and seen before
that's the biggest gift well you're
certainly doing that right now with uh
with women do cry it's on a festival run
right now so that means our audience
likely won't know much about it so would
you mind giving everyone a brief
description of what women do cry is
about
so women who cry
we started working on the project
back in 2019 maybe even 20 2018 it was
very very long ago very much long ago uh
and the whole process of working was
from a complete secret because
i went to an audition which was a blind
audition and it was like you just have
to improvise something imagine that this
and that and this and that and this and
that is happening and i was like oh my
god that sounds exciting that was before
borat so the beginning i had no idea
what is it going to be about then when i
finally joined the project
i read the script the original script
that has been written by our writer and
actress biliana kazakova um and i was
absolutely inspired to work on it
because this
the story of the movie uh follows a
family of women five women three sisters
and
two sisters that are daughters from
four
daughters of the older sister um
whichever each of them goes through a
difficult time in their life and they
get reunited because
no matter how much they fight each other
and i think we all can rely on that
because somehow we're even way more
honest and direct with our family people
that we know are gonna love us and we
love
um we can see and women decry this
so dreamed women female solidarity which
is crucial because we always hear about
men are so solider to each other but we
can see that women will stand up for
each other and at the end they're going
to hold your hand and they're going to
go
through the darkness with you searching
for the light and yeah it's a very
powerful story about
female rights against
women abuse
against
physical or mental
violence which unfortunately still
exists and i'm
i don't know a little bit
scared that we we keep talking about
that it's 21st century and places all
around the world have seen and
experienced
women
being subjugated still i i don't even
know what is this keep happening so
that's the fight of the movie from my
point of view that we just want to be
seen we just want to be heard we just
want to have
as much as we want to have kids we want
to have careers as well and one of them
should not accept the other part because
why should you be described only as a
housewife when you can have a baby and
you can have a career you should not be
just
i don't know if you want to yes go for
it but you should not be described by
the patriarchy world the society that
you're worthless in a way so that's the
fight of the movie and
it's very challenging because
the way that we worked
was
leading in a way of extremeness and i
can pretty much compare it to a
theatrical play because
you know
the eye of the camera is very sensitive
but
our filmmakers were guiding us in a
direction that we just have to do it we
just have to be brave we just have to
dare to
go bigger and stronger and more extreme
because we didn't know
where the end point is and that's the
beauty of
working on something like that
it's scary though but it's cool i feel
like powerful is an understatement in
describing this movie it's like i could
sit there and describe it to people all
day long like you will not feel the full
force of this movie until you see it for
yourself and your performance is
something else i wanted to go back to
the idea of a blind audition so you do a
blind audition for this and then when
you get the script and you read what
your character is struggling through and
the types of scenes you'll have to do
like is there any hesitation at that
point like i don't know if i'm ready for
this this seems like a lot
well it is a very unique process because
i don't know it's just probably my luck
in my life when i'm always going with
these blind auditions and i'm ending up
and some craziness um
but when i read the script when i saw
the story when i felt the story that
we're talking about 18 years old 19
years old girl and it's based pretty
much on real events that have happened
around people that we know friends
relatives
that
are still hurt by
other people's behavior based on the
things that are happening in their life
um i was thrilled and i was
extremely moved and i wanted to to be a
part of it and i wanted to
i wanted to take care of this girl and i
wanted to hold her hand and fight all
the people that
have made her feel in a certain way um
it was scary because you're going to
something
that so many people are afraid to talk
about
problems that people are ashamed of in a
way
which
again for me it's ridiculous but it was
scary it was definitely scary i
i was afraid
will i actually
go there if i go there
how dangerous we'll be can i come back
because with all this metadata thing uh
and we with all the scenes locations
that we showed people that we worked
with
some of them are like real doctors some
of them are real
people from the village that she's going
everybody basically
respond to their character in a way so
for me it was challenging
to do it but we worked
for a long time
on the script
on table and i did a lot of research
what is it like to to live with
the diagnosis of hiv positivity in 21st
century
2020 for god's sake and how still people
all around the world are
somehow afraid to talk about it
without even knowing that with one feel
you actually can have a full life you
can still have babies you can still have
a career you can still have a fulfilled
life and it's something that people
should know because
if you know it you're not gonna
be that scared and you should not be
described by society and in a way of
like oh my god is she gonna die no she's
not and we have to support people
um no matter what is what are they going
through but it was scary it was
definitely scary and exciting and
i mean my fullest my biggest inspiration
my whole life has been danish cinema and
the movement 95
created by lars von trier and thomas
winterberg so being a part of something
that kind of reminds me of that
has been the dream
i love hearing that all right we do have
one more movie to briefly touch on now
it's bodies bodies bodies i feel like
post borat you couldn't have chosen like
any other like more different movies to
jump into from that
so first with that one
are you a big har genre fan in general
is that something that's always appealed
to you well you know the scariest part
is that
i'm actually scared to watch horror
movies but there's something very
how to say it
very addictive in a24 horror movies
because they're always so visually
beautiful and it's like oh my god that's
a piece of piece of art and you just
want to look at it and it's just wow
mind-blowing with hereditary and
mid-summer and so many others that's
just the first two that are coming to my
mind and
reading the script in one breath
being excited to see what is it going to
happen at the end for god's sake
uh i was like
i'm dying to be a part of this having a
24 as a distributor as a production
company as everything i was like i'm
absolutely
excited to join the process and to work
with helena rayne who is an incredible
female filmmaker she's also european uh
she is dutch and her sensitivity her
movie previous movie went to carmen when
the grand prix called instinct i was
beyond excited and thrilled and
flattered to be to be a part of
something that she creates because
the movie speaks a lot to me her movie
previous one instinct the relationship
between a mother and a daughter and
being a woman and
meeting
i mean i'm not gonna give spoilers
because the movie is just incredible and
you if you haven't seen it you just have
to see it um so that's why i was
extremely excited i was scared to be a
part of a horror movie because i'm
scared of horrors
but a24 horror movies are something
different plus i think at the end
body's body's bodies feels more like an
r-rated comedy
because everybody brought their
funniness in a way we were the whole
cast was
incredible i mean these are all people
that i'm dying to work over and over and
over and over again with amanda
steinberg my hala harold rachel sanad
uh chasey wonders p davidson lee pace
they're just so incredible
and it's been beyond exciting so i'm
i'm counting
the minutes the hours for the movie to
be out and seeing and heard about it
because it's it's cool it's fresh
it's unique it's funny
and yeah
i'm i'm super excited it's super
exciting i'll throw in one more question
about that one before we have to wrap up
here so
you just name dropped a whole bunch of
wonderful co-stars there is there
anything you saw anyone do while you
were on set making that movie that you
put in your back pocket and said to
yourself i want to try that on my next
movie because i really admire it
wow
uh wow i love this question um it was
actually super interesting for me
because i'm coming from a theatrical
training 10 years of theater drama
theater from
break to check to
i don't know
stringberg and um
[Music]
and every different kind of theatrical
training that you can imagine
but being in movies and in movie
education we don't really have that so
meeting people that are young and that
are coming also from most of them from
theatrical training as well some of them
comedians was interesting as a workshop
for me because i remember we were
talking
somebody was telling me that before
every single scene before every single
work day
they
they create a playlist that responds
only to the character for example or
somebody else was telling me something
that she always
um what is it called changing completely
her closet and
taking new clothes for
that she's
it's somehow outside inside work of art
which i haven't done before but it's
something that i started doing like
creating a playlist completely for this
character and
trying to imagine that i'm living this
life now so there are a lot of
interesting things how to clean yourself
after a day of work and especially when
you're working on a horror set
you need that
well i have to let you go i feel like i
could talk to you all day i have a
million more questions i'd love to ask a
huge congratulations on women's pride
women do cry is phenomenal and i have
all the faith in the world and body's
body's body so big congratulations and
enjoy south by southwest
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you it's been a pleasure